three two one boom and we're live what's
happening Joe what's up Mike Tom Segura
now that man minutes yeah man by to say
hi I can't believe you've never had a
cup of coffee
never you want something no that might
be that might be the most outrageous
thing about you is that you've never had
coffee your whole life did you just teen
over coffee no one ever offered you a
cup of coffee you never went to
Starbucks no fortieth from donut Wow
what about like adults when you're on
when I was in um that wasn't me getting
rehab it was a little star book because
the means right outside at Starbucks you
always hang out at Starbucks right but
never for the coffee you didn't want to
try it
never hmm that is that how about like
like girlfriends wives like none of them
ever like drank coffee at home I'm sure
they have I never really my wife drinks
it and you just nothing no nothing no no
well I'm so drugged that did you think
coffee would be nothing yeah yeah like
it doesn't make any sense when when did
you first try any drugs kid you're
kidding what kind of [ __ ] smoking and
drinking right then as I got older I
tried acid how old we meet you first try
to ask me eleven Wow Jesus man wow
that's really young Wow
but when you were the champ when you're
in your prime like when you wouldn't
like when you beat Trevor Berbick were
you doing anything back then its
drinking a lot drinking a lot really
yeah that's amazing
would you go clean for camp or like if
it can't you just for camping if it can
yeah but outside like once fights over
yeah yeah yeah you were the first guy
that I ever used as an example of to
break that old myth that you can't have
sex before fights and I was like well
that's out the window for sure cuz you
you talk about it all the time you blow
yeah yeah yeah I'm pretty much yeah your
logic made sense to you like I don't
want to think about it I don't want to
be thinking about sex I'll just get it
out of the way yeah and it's over with
yeah - do you have
we feel for the next time six weeks and
yes going to fight do you think that was
a myth that it made you weak yeah I
think it's a myth yeah doesn't seem to
make sense it seems odd yeah and then
that like whenever they buy you more so
than you know disintegrate you yeah I
would think they said that the Olympic
you know where the athletes stay is just
like [ __ ] or just anything so yeah
also probably want to alleviate some
anxiety anxiety freaking out you're at
the Olympics you know 18 years old and
everyone's in amazing shape stressed out
yeah when you were when you were first
coming up and when you were first uh we
like when you were kid dynamite on
Sports Illustrated I'll never forget
that man that was a that your era from
like you know the the 80s the late 80s
that era like it was a big part of my
youth you know like you being cam and
you being the chant was like it was a
change of things because when Larry
Holmes was the champ as a boxing fan
I loved Larry Holmes like there's that
cover you were 19 years old yeah it's
nuts
when Larry Holmes is a champ as a boxing
fan Wow you still got that stuff man you
just still get those yeah Sports
Illustrated it's the internet you find
it oh yeah that's how Jamie got it I had
that Sports Illustrated but when Larry
Holmes was a champ as a boxing fan I
appreciated him I knew he was a great
fighter I you know we would get together
with friends and watch like the the
Michael Spinks fight with Larry Holmes
yeah when Spinks beat him for the title
it was a big deal but it wasn't a big
deal
culturally yeah people didn't care as
much but then you came around and when
you came around all of a sudden
everybody's watching heavyweight boxing
heavyweight boxing wasn't it wasn't
boring again it was the the most crazy
exciting thing in sports when your
fights would go on it would be about
should I pay for this because how long
is this gonna last but dad never had
it's really weird people tell me about
the time they all chipped in and dad a
fire underneath oh I know
think about it like that you know
sometimes when they come from our
realization of the situation I forget
that I'm that guy forget that I trained
that hard and I became a fighter and
yeah that's what I was going to ask you
like D does it seem like a dream yeah
pretty much like a blur because I
couldn't imagine what it would be like
to be 19 years old 20 years old that
[ __ ] famous it was a trip who can
handle that is then can anybody handle
that no it's a trip but it was just what
custom model you know that was his
blueprints they make me write teenage
superstar did he give you advice on how
to handle pressure and fame and Oh
depression everything but you know if
there's really no ingredients on how to
handle thing you know I mean we have to
see what what Department of Fame is your
problem and we have to work on that
issue from there but you know no one's
know how to conduct himself under that
kind of pressure
no doctor it's at the level of Fame -
yes like there's so many you realize
there's so many levels of Fame and then
Mike's is still just extraordinary where
like people people walk away from their
job like in an airport they're supposed
to be at the cash register and they run
out you know they leave their job to go
say hi that's not you know most of the
time you like oh that's who that person
is it's a totally different thing how
where does that that's pretty weird [ __ ]
away from me man don't creep I might
come in pick up it your mother pick up
it to my kid take a picture here take a
picture I love you Justin I'm like whoa
dude cool out but now you know anything
this is just what it is it is what it is
stop it yeah I've seen you at the UFC
before you're very calm around people
when people grabbing at you want to take
pictures you just just relax the USD is
awesome cause everybody's not